I'm Tim were Quran professor of
economics and political science at Duke
University I've been asked to comment on
what one thing would really help to
create jobs in the Arab world reducing
and in fact eliminating trade barriers
within the Arab world would drastically
increase efficiency and add enormous
numbers of jobs by promoting trade
within the Arab world currently there
are trade barriers among all of the Arab
countries many Arab countries do more
trade than they with Egypt and Italy
than they do with all of the other Arab
I'm sorry with Turkey and Italy than
they do with all of the other Arab
countries combined the size of the
entire Arab economy combined is about
the size of Spain imagine if Spain had
every province within Spain had had
barriers preventing trades between the
provinces there would be enormous
efficiency losses and Spain would be
nowhere as wealthy as it is currently
that is the situation that the Arab
world is in today to stop there